[Applause]
her new book is in true
this is ridiculous but her new book is
in Trump we trust he pluribus awesome
look remember what we say now be nice
when they go low we go high
let's go high with a nice greeting for
Ann Coulter
[Applause]
working tear ivis how long have we been
doing this for 23 years right start
since 93 was when well I didn't I'm I
was practicing law was 98 or 97 or 98
going away with the miniskirt that's all
I could say so how's the campaign going
fantastic thanks for asking um
apparently they're not that confident in
the media that it's gonna be this 50
state landslide for Hillary or they
wouldn't be pulling out all these
ridiculous charges three weeks before
the election well okay look looks like a
Hail Mary pass to me Rory did you think
the charges are all ridiculous yes what
do you think the same thing about the
Bill Cosby charges no there everybody
had heard about that for years I mean
look you know perfectly well and this
isn't what we're talking about okay
um because it's stupid um yeah very
stupid but look what with with somebody
like Bill Clinton his introduction to
the minute the American people was for
him and his wife to go on after the
Super Bowl and why did the American
people if everybody knew about it for
years same thing with Bill Cosby you
heard about it for years you knew about
a few years as you well know you were a
wealthy man you were celebrity I mean
this was like believing something in in
divorce records wealthy men are going to
attract a lot of lawsuits he's working
with a lot of women this has never
happened until three weeks before the
election give me a break then let's then
let's just dig that cuz that's he said
she said I happen to believe them but
okay let's just stick to what he said
let's get to the issue wait what that is
an issue why am i okay all right look
all right let me ask it all right just
give me no one is voting for Donald
Trump because of his character or
personality win never were it was always
about his issues and this is coming on
so that we can't talk about the issues
which is what I really want to talk
about we will let me ask one question
okay if there was a tape of Obama cuz
you say this is not a big thing even
what he said again reducing what he said
about I put a search in my mouth I mean
a tic-tac plug for search
I put it yeah he's gonna sing about your
hacker okay wealthy men can do anything
man I don't know if you were alone wait
not it's not the condition it's nothing
so each a with rich man and celebrity
I remember what you've ever heard that
before bill I remember only saying and I
remember my grammar and I bet you you do
also I was of Catholic upbringing the
the subjective temps were he's not
saying if I were he's saying I win he's
saying I'd do this let me read the quote
when you're a star I better use some
tic-tacs you do anything I just in case
I start kissing her I just start kissing
them
I don't even wait and when you're a star
they let you do it okay here's my one
question if you'd be quiet'
I could just ask it we built a pond
Hilary's my question is if a tape of
Obama had come out at some point during
his presence you know where he said hey
fruity give me a tic-tac uh cuz I'm
thinking about kissing a woman I've
never met mm-hmm
would there be any kind of outcry on the
right or would you just also will do
would that have just like gone by the
boards and you would have said that's
locker room talk um I would not believe
probably anything from a hot Mike's
alleged from the hot light typer or care
about these charges if it's right before
an election I mean everybody sofa
boatman did it would be okay yes because
I really want to talk about the reason
we support Donald Trump the reason there
is a civil war but I will say that
everyone in television has said horrible
things on hot mics that you wouldn't
want to get out there not like this um
no they're different things but you for
no matter how different matter
you are lots of people have said totally
American things there are three people
we've heard the hot mic type tapes from
Bill O'Reilly Laura Ingraham and Donald
Trump they're hot mic tapes on everybody
it's humiliating for everybody this is
all-out war for Trump and why is it all
out war on Trump because he is
absolutely right it is the American
people against the UN a party of both
the Democrats on my party that I never
saw until Trump came along they want
open borders as Hillary said in her hot
mic tape open borders that will crush
the wages of not only the working class
but the middle class um it's the trade
deals to send any jobs that happen to
already been sent to Mexico and send
them to Asia it's because of the endless
war that your candidate wants to now
start with your up shop alright that's I
give out Trump you win you've you've
answered my question predict Obama had
said it it would have been a no big deal
okay I'll tell you it would be no big
deal if he were against TPP it would be
no big deal if he were the only
candidate who wanted to build wall it
would be no big deal if you were the
only candidate who wanted extreme
vetting for oh you know immigrants whose
religion teaches them to kill us as
opposed to quadrupling that are you
gonna defend that Bill Maher okay let me
ask you let's go back to the immigrants
we're bringing in whose religion teaches
them to kill us so that they slaughter
50 people at a gay nightclub in Orlando
do you think we should be giving them an
extra look cuz your candidate wants to
quadruple the the immigration of um of
your slums is religion teacher some they
want to kill let me ask you about this
New York Times piece because you were
the star but it was a couple of weeks
ago thank you and you you really were
and and I mean it would talked about how
the fact that when Donald Trump made his
announcement speech there was only a
couple of lines in there about
immigration but he had read your book
the one you plugged on this very
magnificent book well it certainly was
to him yes I mean I did not realize
until I read that article how much
influence you have had on Donald Trump
you still think he's gonna win um I
think it's more likely than not but that
gives a big chance for her to win I mean
I always thought it was about 90% chance
he wins the nomination about 60% chance
he wins the election will know Election
Day um because he I mean he really is
he's issues that one's people what you
love the most
you said he could perform abortions in
the White House I know that as long as
he keeps that immigration policy right
but the wall huh he stopped talking
about the wall really well he hasn't
mentioned in either debate it's not on
his website anymore this is my old doing
they won't there has not been one
question about immigration this is why
he is right about the media they do want
to turn this into everything about his
personal baggage I Got News for You we
knew we had personal baggage we knew he
was allowed right but he's the only one
who will do anything about the working
class in this country and by the way as
I also said on that show pushing a diós
America um who did I say was the
toughest Democrat room to run against
Bernie Sanders because he to hang on
you're not gonna like me but you should
like me um because we agree on the wall
on this dump of low-wage workers on the
country you don't agree on the wall well
you shadow think Bernie's for I want you
to invite me on the panel with him
because his position never heard I would
like to build the wall
I never heard but he did say yeah
Morgan's direct quote open borders know
that the wall retail open open borders
that's a coke brothers policy occur she
is right Donald Trump is right what do
the Koch brothers Rupert Murdoch and
George Soros agree on open borders TPP
okay
it is the Union Party against a peep I
know you think that the the world is
coming to an end if you could no it
isn't not if someone did you would you
steal look if you could would you steal
this election would is it visit that bad
that you that you justify stealing we
don't steal elections your party does oh
but if you but if you could would you is
it that dyers at worth out doing this no
but I can do what I would imagine would
you you know what about whatever what
about try whenever was David Duke versus
Hillary Clinton what's his position on
TPP and open border well of course not
give me a break would you vote for David
Duke to stop Trump is he that different
I'll give me a break some three please
white supremacy
I don't think I don't even think David
Duke exists I appears every four years
you can use him as a boogeyman and ask
not look dinner on gnome does not talk
to a Johnson found him had him speak at
the convention Hillary has the terrorist
father who shot up the Orlando nightclub
sitting behind her to rally can we have
her disavow him you know what the okay
you know there's another terrorist
father the one who had the chicken stand
said to the FBI my son is the terrorist
that's a patriot much more than Donald
Trump
that's gotcha yeah that's true
okay but look this is taxpayer money
that is being spent there are thousands
of Investigations to follow Muslim
immigrants they are in all 50 states
Alaska and Hawaii instead of spent with
that is money that should be spent on
our own poor people on our own
working-class on our own plants and ends
and building the wall to help the
American people why are we bringing in
people who are so expensive
yeah you want to keep going with this
mass brettly's bringing yours you want
to transport post 9/11 here for the
ninth Asian play now when you were here
before you said the fact that the
deportation plan is letting ice do its
job okay but you said they're not really
12 million you know they're more like
Saturday 30 40 50 we don't know so to
deport 30 million it's gonna be a little
expensive no but we're already paying
later you know hey once you have the
wall guess who doesn't have to collect
unemployment insurance go home and sleep
got injured on the job a wall just sits
there night and day without any work all
right you build my god I got a nice does
their job we're already paying ice all
right Ann Coulter her book as Trump is
great thank you so much